between 2004 and 2008 I unsuccessfully
tried to get into the Kenyan music
industry but the recurring anza from
producers was I was not Kenyan enough
meaning what I didn't sing fully in the
slang derivative of kiswahili and I
didn't sing enough Patti tracks so they
said Kenyans wouldn't listen to a Kenyan
who sounded like me this idea of other
ism the exclusion of a person based on
the perceived deviation from the norms
goes to the root of the problems in
Kenya and it runs deep henna was
invented by colonialism 1895 and with it
came the airasia of our identity and the
class system built on other ism so by
1963 when we received our independence
these ideas had already become the new
normal
now we've tried a lot of different ways
to move forward since we have a common
language currency infrastructure
basically all the things that make a
country a country but all these efforts
at nation-building do not go to the
heart of the matter which is this we
cannot build what we do not truly love
and we cannot love until we love
ourselves the thing we have to heal as
Kenyans is our lack of self-love our
deep self hate and our existential
identity crisis and this is the work of
nation-building that only the creative
industry can do the idea that Kenya can
only include some of us led me to found
a music festival in 2008 called blankets
and wine to give a platform to myself
and other misfits 10 years later we've
programmed over 200 bands and put at
least $100,000 directly into the hands
of artists and managers who have interns
spend it on technicians rehearsals music
videos and other things along the music
value chain our platform has allowed for
multiple Kenyan identities to exist
while inspiring the industry to discover
and engage the wide variety
of Kenyan music what we do is necessary
but insufficient and we must urgently
pivot into a live music circuit but
there are other ways music can help heal
the nation according to a 2018 state of
media report traditional radio is still
by far the biggest distributor of ideas
in Kenya with 47% of Kenyans still
choosing radio fast this presents an
opportunity we can use radio to help
Kenyans hear the diversity that is Kenya
we can't reserve 60% of our programming
on Kenyan radio for Kenyan music we can
break down ethnic barriers by playing
Kenyan music done in English Swahili and
other ethnic languages on what is now
single language ethnic radio radio can
help stimulate interest and demand for
Kenyan music by Kenyans while also
providing the much-needed incomes by way
of royalties but more importantly radio
can help us build a more inclusive
narrative about Kenya for you cannot
love which you do not know exists
other creative industries too can do the
work when you consider that 41% of
Kenyans still choose TV as a primary
medium it's obvious that film has a huge
potential the meager resources that have
been put into the sector have already
produced world-class acts like Lupita
Nyong'o and when Marika Hill but we're
going to need a lot more incentives and
investments to make filming Kenya easier
so mob Kenyan stories can get onto
Kenyan TV and spark off the really
difficult conversations we need to have
with one another we're going to need to
grow a lot more homegrown stars so we
can reverse the idea that we have to
blow up abroad before we get the
acceptance and validation of home
fashion to can do the work we need to
make it possible to affordably
mass-produce Kennan clothes for Kenyan
consumers so we don't all have to rely
on secondhand inputs the first running
shoe made in Kenya needs to be a local
and global success as an ode to Kenyan
excellence epitomized by Kenyan runners
who are literally world class
for these ideas to come to life jobs
will be created and Kenyan ideas will be
exported but more importantly Kenyans
may finally consider themselves worthy
of the love that we reserved for others
Kenya's creative industry is dynamic
cosmopolitan
for looking and without doubt a true
manufacturing industry of the immediate
future but its true power lies in its
ability to help heal the psyche of Kenya
so we can finally build a nation for
real
thank you for this song I'd like us all
to take a minute and think about
immigrant communities and especially
refugee immigrant communities and the
daily struggle they have to endure
building a life with dignity and meaning
away from everything they have loved and
known if you feel any empathy for this
idea I asked to see your fist up in the
air with me million voice
the man debate shop
a million million boys a monk I'm a
chump
young boy then install my mom's dog with
a million million boy
this one dedicated to maki popular some
working hard to make sure that their
children will enough when people come
around and I just wanna tell them to
consider you can see monkey lucky
survive you better we can make watch a
similar many cover runner over
[Music]
enough
sorry way of life
and all the crime
[Music]
yeah
the mundum make some noise not coming me
on Finley on boys the manga make some
noise with Tommy Lee and in Leon boy can
stop I won't stop I familiar can't stop
whoa
hey can I be your leader you not be your
Fiza I'll show you how to make some
money the pledge allegiance is it
already done here you want either but
show you
[Music]
the reason I stood on my grind
have enough of it
[Music]
the Munda make some noise
this next one is partly in Kiswahili
which is what we speak in Kenya and it's
about female friendship and female power
and girls coming together to build
something that lasts a true legacy and
intergenerational one Susan oh my god no
worries we are looking like the home
spin-off Haram matter for all the pretty
boys come on tell us how they walk
[Music]
another drum with a club was Ibaka with
you you
[Music]
I know to another car
young Susan no we ain't got no money by
we do we have wanna I want it now Bobby
all them pretty boys when I harvest but
they feel like Jim jungle yeah robot
that works right the number drops at
that clock buzzer sound she died with
silk
[Music]
I know
now wine wait wait stop no one ever
comes over and a little flower to me
buddy
[Music]
Oh
besides I know all this I know all this
I know I know
[Music]
[Applause]